how about some week six pft props
the browns and the steelers getting
together again for the first time in
2020. remember it was last year in
cleveland on a thursday night that miles
garrett removed the helmet of mason
rudolph and whacked him over the head
with it big ben the guy who would be in
position for that kind of treatment if
it were to repeat itself this time
around had some things to say about
miles garrett here he is
he's a generational type football player
he's really really good he's a guy that
we we have to know where he is and we're
going to have to have multiple guys
blocking him because he is a game
changer he's that good
in other words please don't hit me over
the head with my own helmet
i will praise you as much as i can and
you know it's not as relevant as it
would have been
if mason rudolph were playing in the
game right but it's still part of this
rivalry it's part of the the lore it's
par especially as long as mile garrett
miles garrett is playing for the browns
it doesn't matter who's playing
quarterback we know what he's done when
he's blown a gasket against the steelers
in the past
and uh you know all of a sudden it's a
huge game yeah brown's at four and one
steals at 4-0 steelers really haven't
been tested by anybody good
we'll do our picks on this game coming
up later today for the mega pix
podcast for now though
prop bet miles garrett over under one
and a half sacks against the steelers
chris well i'm gonna go over i mean yeah
mike mason rudolph's not playing but
there was still plenty said you know in
the newspapers and things like that
after that incident happened you know
marquis pounce he's going to be out
there he's the guy that was right in the
middle of that scrum so that's going to
add to it i do think cleveland
feels i think the players in that locker
room may feel that
some things were said or they're a
little bit defensive about how it went
down and they want to defend their
teammate i think there is motivation
there plus the biggest reason i'm going
to go he gets one and a half sacks or
i'm going to go over here
is because pittsburgh can't run the
football and i just think they're going
to be throwing the ball a whole lot and
you just heard there's only you know you
heard what big ben said miles garrett
has gotten into that like
okay it might not be aaron donald but
it's really damn close to where yeah the
stats are good but the amount of plays
he f's up to is really unbelievable as
well he is all over the place run game
pass game he is i think you know
he might he's the second best defensive
player in football now i think he
solidified that spot um but i'm gonna go
with the over
and you know it's funny as it pertains
to finding all sorts of things to
motivate yourself garrett clearly in the
wrong last year
when he removes
the helmet of an opponent and hits him
over the head with it clearly in the
wrong but to the extent that he can use
whatever lingering backlash there may be
is motivation to go out and have more
than one and have sex yeah do it and uh
it works and i think garrett will have a
big day i think the browns are gonna
have a big day against the steelers i
think it's gonna be one of those games
where i don't want to tip my pick but
yeah it's gonna be one of those games
where when it's over we're gonna say
well boy maybe we do need to take this
team seriously win or lose we need to
take the brown seriously packers
definitely need to be taken seriously at
4-0 the buccaneers stepped into a
pothole last thursday night in chicago
more passing yards in this battle of the
goats aaron rodgers or tom brady chris
wow this one's tough uh
because i could see both of them putting
up some some pretty big damn numbers
i
because god you know godwin and evans
are a little banged up
i'm the buccaneers defense is better i'm
gonna go with rogers here and this more
because i just think they're gonna have
to rely on the past the bucks don't let
you run it they'll put five defensive
linemen in the game and even when they
have four
they still have an unbelievable four i
mean they have arguably the best front
line in football you can make that that
argument there to where i have a hard
time thinking they're going to be able
to win the game with aaron jones you
might see a lot of you know aaron jones
yeah we're giving them the ball but it's
more just to keep the buccaneers honest
on that side of the ball and they're
going to look to strike in the pass game
so i'll go with rogers i don't feel
confident about that one though
this one is just so fascinating to me
this will be the third time that tom
brady is in a big spot week one 4 25
eastern against the saints huge rating
much anticipation didn't win yeah
thursday night game last week
national platform
didn't win and now another 4 25 p.m
eastern game on fox with aaron rodgers
coming to town so much pressure i think
on brady to put that that
i i
thought it was fourth down right
nonsense behind him and you know aaron
rodgers with a week to get ready for
this one and and a week to just prove to
everyone that all the love that gets
heaped on tom brady
maybe he should be getting some of it i
think aaron rodgers going to have more
passing yards in this one just because
it does and this is another kind of
apples to apples thing tom brady needs
to have receivers aaron rodgers doesn't
no aaron rodgers does a better job with
nothing than tom brady does so i'll go
aaron rodgers chris yeah i i'm with you
there it's it is it's a great i mean
you're right i think this is probably
the marquee match-up of the weekend or
the one certainly i'm in most interested
in because we think green bay is for
real obviously and then tampa i think
you and i both think they are for real
they haven't solidified that yet though
i mean i was surprised yeah with how
they let that game slip away in chicago
and all of that so we still haven't seen
them play their best football maybe that
doesn't happen but i just see parts
where i go oh it looks really good we'll
see if they can kind of bring it all
together i'm betting yes still are you
you're still
you're still bullish on the the bucks
right
yeah i picked them to go to the super
bowl
after five weeks what do you think in
here yeah well i don't feel good after
last thursday night so we'll see what
they can do with a couple of extra days
and again the packers coming off of
their bye week they had more than a
couple of extra days to get ready and
i've just i've become an aaron rodgers
i have to set that aside i have to set
that aside now and there's just
something about look i've said before he
and i have far more in common than we
don't and that's probably one of the
reasons why there's friction there
because if you're too much like someone
you're not going to get along i i've
i've become this late career aaron
rodgers fan and i'm having a hard time
setting that aside and being objective
about this game because i do want to see
him go to tampa bay and get the win over
tom brady and get some people to realize
that that maybe
the greatness of tom brady had
more than a little to do with the people
who were around him including his
coaching staff in new england all right
rogers you have a new flint fan in
florio
maybe i need to wear an aaron rodgers
journey i think
i'm gonna make yep i think you should
next week speak and then if i'm green
i'll just match the jerseys
no day
it's christmas next week i just look
like uh you know it's all one the
gremlins like that bringing that
thing that they wear all right uh
broncos at patriots this weekend cam
newton over under 40 rushing yards in
his three games this year he's had 75 47
and 27 so the trend has not been his
friend chris is he over under 40. no
over over all the way i just look at it
and go if you're the new england
patriots it's the safe way to go to run
the ball again you know get him back in
a rhythm the the broncos defense
it's not very good i mean we know
they're they're banged up they're a
banged up football team there's not a
lot to talk about on their front you
know front seven to where you go they
got difference makers bradley chubb hey
he pops a little here and there he's
getting there after his acl tear but i
would think that the patriots have their
way with them up front and that cam
newton yeah has a little success
certainly going with the over here
yeah i think so too and you know this
patriots offense is going to be driven
by match up it's not a system per se
that's right same no matter what like
the titans seem to be
but this just feels like a game where
and you kind of knock the rust off cam
newton a little bit this way too get him
out there exactly bang around a little
bit you know get him just feeling like
he's back in the flow after a couple of
weeks away and i agree with you it's
going to be over 40 yards rams four and
one 49ers two and three you know the
49ers are in danger of falling to oh and
four at home through the first half of
their schedule at levi's stadium
two props for this one first
jimmy garoppolo
over under one and a half interceptions
he had none in his first two games this
season he made an early exit from the
week two game against the jets he had
two
last week in that debacle against the
dolphins before he was yanked for cj
beathard over under one and a half
ah this this is
i
man i mean just with jimmy g the way he
looked last week
the way they're playing on the offensive
side of the ball
i mean not pass protecting all that well
and now you got aaron donald coming into
town
man
i'm gonna go under i don't feel good
about that i'm gonna go under just from
the simple fact that he'll be scarred by
the two interceptions he threw last week
and probably should have thrown a few
others as well
and that he'll be ultra protective that
way and that his ankle will be a little
bit better to where he's a little more
effective throwing the ball in doing
that
but i don't feel real good about saying
that i'm going under only because i
think he'll reign it in and realize this
is a big game and i can't be stupid
last week he clearly had no business
playing it was obvious the ankle was
still bothering him he fully
participated in practice on wednesday
would you rather see a 90 percent
garoppolo or a 100 percent cj best oh i
know because last week i don't think
even garoppolo was at 90 right i mean i
think it was probably like 75 something
like that i mean there was a real you
could really tell watching the game back
that there was an issue there
with him
make it i guess i'm still going to go 90
i'm still going to go garoppolo i am i
don't know if i trust cj beathard enough
yet to say that i don't so i will go
with garoppolo garoppolo still knows
where to go with the ball
and when i say 90 i think okay yeah he's
at 90 which means he's strong enough to
put his foot in the ground there and
really drive off that back right leg
which is his hurt ankle and make
effective throws so yes but that that's
a close one mike
all right next one same prop different
game we had one and a half sacks is the
over under for miles garrett it's also
the over under for aaron donald what are
you taking
i i i feel like i got to go with the
over i i just i do i mean i
banged up a little up front especially
at the guard position they got a little
issue there in san francisco yeah i mean
they're gonna find ways to get aaron
donald you know matched up on whoever
that guy is ben garland or not you know
brunskill number six uh 60. he's the
right guard right now who had some
issues last week
i would think they're going to find ways
to make sure he gets one on one and i
mean really every week
aaron donald is basically a two sack guy
if he doesn't get two sacks in a week
it's just because like he missed by a
smidgen like seven times where the guy
just threw the ball away or as he's
swinging in the quarterback to the
ground he threw it and you know didn't
get intentional grounding he's unreal
i've never seen anything like him like i
said aaron donald has entered the
conversation of one of the greatest
defensive players in the history of
football he is up there with those type
of people now and i'm going over there
yeah i agree with you as well it's
incredible and i still think back to
that 2014 draft and all those teams that
passed on him that there should be the
same regret for those teams as there is
for the team passed on patrick mahomes
that's how good aaron donald is one of
the best of all time and he's still
smack dab in the middle of his prime and
who knows how long he's gonna be able to
keep it up and he's probably gonna keep
it up for a very long time all right
bears four and one panthers three and
two panthers the favorites in this one
which is kind of stunning who's got more
receptions alan robinson of the bears or
robbie anderson of carolina i'm going to
go with alan robinson here and not that
the bears are the most high-flying
offense in the world and everything like
that carolina's certainly been better on
defense than i expected but robinson is
clearly their best target in the past
game clearly and
with this carolina defense they'll he'll
have opportunities to catch some passes
here and i would think
excuse me there why i'm uh swallowing
and burping my coffee but i would think
it yes they're gonna feed alan robinson
a lot where on the other side of the
ball as good as robbie anderson is the
bears have seen how much he's been
getting the ball the bears defense is
very good and
carolina has other weapons i mean you
know robbie anderson's having
statistically the better year i'm not
sure i think he's the best receiver on
their team i think it's very close with
dj moore too who's an awesome player so
they have that option to go that way if
they want to the bears don't really it's
alan robinson he's the guy i'm going to
go with him
yeah i am as well and look robbie
anderson has been kind of a favorite for
teddy bridgewater but i think back on
what khalil mack did last thursday night
against the buccaneers and man
i don't know teddy's going to have a
whole lot of time to throw to anyone
they might know sunday when the bears
come to town especially with and this
gets back to the titans finding
motivation in everyone pointing out they
have a covet 19 outbreak the bears i
think are going to get plenty of
motivation from the fact that they're
four and one
and they're
underdogs against a rebuilding team that
has strung three wins together somehow
all right bengals one three and one at
the three and two colts jonathan taylor
who became the starting tailback when
marlon mack suffered a torn achilles
tendon weak one over under 80 yards for
taylor his rushes by start
101 59
68 57 is he over under 80 chris uh i'm
gonna go over i this they got to get
back to running the football in
indianapolis you know again and their
losses the one thing we've seen is
philip rivers has had to throw too much
and they lose i mean that's all there is
to it they still have a great offensive
line i know costanzo was hurt last week
and all that yeah
okay but uh the way their team is built
right now they're built to play smash
mouth play through your defense and
phillip make a play every now and then
in the pass game
that's their best way to win football
games in my opinion the bengals can't
stop the run at all i mean they got
issues they just lost dj reader for the
year
i would think this is something that
jumps out on film and frank wright goes
you know what let's get back to the
basics quentin nelson pulling guard
start smashing faces again and they get
back on track that way
um
who's been more underwhelming this year
as rookie running backs go even though
they haven't been bad
but let's say who's been less
overwhelming i don't want to be dissing
jonathan taylor and clyde edwards
hilaire but which guys which guy's been
been uh more impressive of the two all
things considered um
it's really close
i think overall
i still think i'm gonna go with jonathan
taylor here i know there's that first
game by clyde edwards hilaire right we
we know that yes
but you know i i i see within jonathan
taylor some moments of where i go man he
looks good i mean you know your your
vikings defense i i won't say yours
anymore because i know you're off the
bandwagon but thank you ran well and
successful in that football game you
know
that cleveland browns defensive front's
been pretty damn good so they did a good
job last week but i don't think they
really tried to feature him and then the
week before that who was the bears where
they know they're a really good front
seven that's it's hard to run the ball
on them so
uh you know i'm gonna go with taylor but
either way i will say i have not been as
impressed with either one as much as i
expected to be going into the year
yeah you know i agree with you and they
both started strong uh and they both
have kind of fizzled out a little bit
relative to how they started and it's
funny how if you make a good first
impression you can carry that for a
while yeah people still think oh clyde
edwards ooh jonathan taylor and the
performance hasn't been where we thought
it was going to be but there's still
plenty of time left we'll see how they
perform moving forward chiefs at bills
monday night football the early game
more totally
or homie my homie mahomey or your boy
blue josh allen blue
i don't know what to do here
my boy blue versus my homie your homie
my homie you're homie
i don't i mean first off i'm i'm cannot
wait to watch this you know all those
things i said about rogers and brady in
the marquee matchup i take him off the
table i forgot about this game this is
the one i'm most excited to see but
i i
i'm gonna go with i'm gonna go with my
homes
i'm gonna go with my homes because
only because i worry about the buffalo
defense more than i do the kansas city
defense the buffalo defense can't rush
the passer right now they don't have
good cover corners jordavious white's
not a hundred percent
that's just oh that's scary
against against uh the kansas city
chiefs and and mahomes you know the
chiefs we know they'll they'll take some
chances on defense and let up some big
plays here and there but spagnulo
spagnolo is one of those guys too that
you just said like about the titans and
the patriots
the defense changes every week it's it's
specific game plan you can't look at
kansas city and go oh they're this type
of defense and they play that all the
time no they're going to play it
specific to how they feel is going to
give them the best chance to win the
football game um to where i think
they'll throw a few more curve balls at
josh allen than maybe mahomes will get
from mcdermott
yeah this one's gonna be tough and this
one both teams are so desperate i just i
think it's gonna be my homes because i
think this is one of those
games where you get the full focus of
the kansas city chiefs this is going to
be one of those where patrick was going
to muhammad is going to find some reason
to count something he's going to count
something right he's going to do
something he's going to have an extra
edge to himself after losing to the
raiders unexpectedly and having this
platform on monday night even though
it's not the official monday night game
it's still monday night football
it's nationally broadcast that's right
this is a big deal and and i think the
bills are going to have their full
attention and the bills are in disarray
a little bit defensively after what
happened to them against the titans so
yeah i think mahomes will have more
total touchdowns i i mean i you know
that i mean this is going to be so cool
and fun to watch you know you got to
think that that josh allen you know he's
going to be aware of the moment too he's
had this great year and then he gets to
play a game on national tv and tuesday
night and still made some unreal plays
but had two interceptions right one
which wasn't his fault but he's going to
want to put a better foot forward too
they've had this little throw off
competition conversation about who could
throw it farther and all that and i
would say as far as making magic happen
like the way mahomes makes it happen
josh allen is probably second in
football to be the most like him that
way you know i know rogers and russell
wilson make magic but they do it a
little different way i mean like you saw
the other night i mean josh allen was
doing mahomes stuff fading away in the
pocket throwing the ball across the
field to stefan diggs on a third and
nine makes a 30-yard throw across the
field oh another play is floating in the
pocket 45-yard laser in the back of the
end zone to tj yeldon i mean that is the
only guy that's kind of doing that right
now is mahomes and
and allen so that's where i'm really
excited to see it because the weapons
they have at their disposal they're both
defenses will give up some plays um yeah
but i'm with you i'm going with my homes
but i am very excited to watch this one
as you could tell
yeah and you know there's just that
fundamental difference between when
and and i'd say the range is this
russell wilson
when he makes magic happen
it's so seamless you don't even realize
exactly what you're doing right
when mahomes does it
there's a flare to it it's the are you
not entertained it's making it exciting
and getting you on the edge of your seat
but you know how it's going gonna end
yeah it's it's you know you know it's
gonna work out when it's all said and
done with alan
he's the guy who's walking on the
tightrope yeah right with
with no net
and the wind is blowing and you really
don't know what's going to happen right
and and i think that in and of itself
makes it exciting but it seems like he's
the one of the three who is the most
likely
to have something
bad happen yeah when he gets into that
mode where he's just trying to make
something good happen no doubt you know
that perception's still there i think
it's still real i think it's he's
washing it away or if you're paying
attention enough it should be starting
to wash away with people you know last
year it improved that way this year
again it's improving and i know people
look at the other night but damn you
know again people he's gonna make a few
mistakes here and there the game is all
on him you know it's all about hey josh
drop back and we're throwing rifles and
bombs all over the field let's go make
some plays and yeah it's a little bit
you know
pants on fire whatever and all of that
but it's still more times than not it's
getting to the point where you go well
it could be a disaster oh man good play
good play i we're saying that a whole
lot more now the other night it came up
again there you know in the third
quarter on that first drive yeah i think
he was fooled by malcolm butler and what
he did he tried to throw a cover two
hole shot over there malcolm butler kind
of looked like he was going to jump the
slot route and then duped him and kind
of got back and it caught alan by
surprise but you know for the most part
he's been mistake-free for the whole
year we'll see if he can keep that going
because you're right that's the amazing
thing about mahomes that's the thing i
marvel about my homes and rogers two
greatest gunslingers maybe we've ever
seen and they take care of the ball as
good as anybody we've ever seen and
that's that's where they're really
special
last game of the week the monday night
official game after chiefs and bills are
over cardinals and the cowboys andy
dalton taking the place of dak prescott
over under 300 passing yards for dalton
and
dak prescott was on pace to obliterate
the single season passing record so this
is a passing offense does the red rifle
fire up more than the length of three
football fields on monday night chris uh
i would think so i'm gonna say yes i
don't know if it'll go much over that
uh i don't but i just still think that
they're still gonna play through the
pass game i don't know if their run game
is good enough for where they're just
gonna be able to go like oh we're gonna
pound the rock and impose our will on
you that way
i think with those weapons and he's
still got a you know a really good right
arm and knows how to play football
that yeah he'll go like
just a little over 300 you know i don't
think we're going to see 390 or 450 like
we were seeing with dak prescott i think
they'll try to run the ball a little bit
more but i still think it's going to be
a pass first offense so i'll go over
yeah i agree
yeah yeah but he can do it look this is
a guy it's amazing how perceptions can
change so dramatically so quickly this
is a guy who took a team that really
didn't have a ton of superstars to the
playoffs five straight years and yeah
they didn't want a playoff game but they
still made it five straight years to go
back to zero and zero when you keep
losing in round one is not an easy thing
to do because at some point you're just
like what the hell what's the point we
know what's waiting for us and and then
there were a few years where he was just
kind of lost in the wilderness with a
team that was disintegrating he's got a
better
set of skill position players than he
ever had
at his time in cincinnati in any given
year when you consider all those
receivers when you consider ezekiel
elliott i think he can go over i think
he will go over i think i i hope i mean
i'm at the point where i want 38 35 41
38 35 32. i want those every week that
should be on the bingo card
i should be on the bingo card
i like high scoring bingo i like high
scoring football sorry i i like i like
exciting football you don't um but i
think it'll be exciting and i think andy
dalton will go over 300 yards i like
exciting football too i like to see a
good 17-14 or 2019 game every now and
then like we saw last thursday night
it really puts pressure on the players
the coaches is what i really enjoy it
puts pressure on them to actually have
to manage a game instead of just going
let's call the bomb again oh touchdown
look at that i'm a genius this is
amazing i like to see the pressure going
to the coaches i like to see if a coach
might stupidly throw the ball on second
and nine and give the greatest
quarterback of all time a minute and 13
left like that was fun like whoa that
was stupid and then you know brady trump
that with not knowing what down it was
um but
uh yeah i'm with you with the andy dawn
thing cardinals their defense
statistically good against the pass but
they haven't really played any good pass
offenses you know other than carolina
and maybe detroit okay and they lost
both of those games so i would think
that the dallas can have some of those
matchups there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports